can i ask you mark how old you are i'm
45. 45. all right so you're not old
enough i'm i'm thinking well i guess you
are a gen xer right yeah ian you're
barely a gen x 42 yeah last year i was
watching the music video for gotta get
away by the offspring oh you're familiar
with the uh my high school band opened
for them for the offspring no way for
real for real wow cool was your band
called uh a really crappy high school
band no one's ever heard of uh what what
what year did you shout out this was
this was literally like
a month before smash came out this would
have been like 1993 at the madrona hill
winery which is a venue in portland that
no longer exists which by the way it's a
really bad idea to have underage bands
playing at a wine ranch yeah it is
out there so the offspring story i was
reading about it so when i was younger
they were like my favorite band when i
was like a little kid learning play
guitar
and now they're just
amazing corporate shills they fired
their drummer because he couldn't get
vaccinated because he has guillain-barre
syndrome and so i was just like
reading about you know that their album
ignition
sold i think 15 000 copies when it first
came out i think it was epitaph and then
when smash came out it just took the
country by storm i think it might still
be like the biggest selling record to
ever come out in an independent record
yes that's fact that's true and so these
guys were like true punk rock
underdogs they weren't really going to
go anywhere and then all of a sudden it
was mainstream
i'm watching this music video forgot to
get away which was i think it was their
third single off of smash which is like
as you mentioned the biggest independent
release of all time
and i see these like young people
moshing and you know just raging out and
like this teenage angst from gen x and
now gen x have become such like
pro-establishment shills rage on behalf
of the machine they're just totally in
favor of the machine bad religion
totally in favor of the machine tom
morello is doing a newsletter for the
new york times right now
he has done one of those masterclass
things i mean
it's i
he is like the poster boy for selling
out so you're a little bit young i guess
though but like what happened man i mean
you were old enough to see smash come
out you played
what happened to this generation how did
they go from being
like
what you got to understand about a punk
album
that this music was not popular it was
not mainstream
and then all of a sudden a million
albums are sold or whatever it's like is
smashing records and all of a sudden now
it is becoming mainstream i guess these
people the the offspring have a song on
their first album whose name i can't say
because it's a crime to say i'm not
kidding
they removed it eventually it's no
longer the only way you could listen to
it on youtube by finding the full album
version and then it's the last song on
the album
we cannot say the name of this song it
is a crime to say because it involves
the president spicy they get rid of it
eventually
so it's almost like these these these
guys are anti-establishment up until
someone slides the money under their
door and then all of a sudden they're
willing to fellate the state
so i'm kind of a music journalist and i
could go off forever on the whole you
know alternative indie thing and like
what happened specifically there but
just to go back to sort of the the
broader cultural thing um
there's this humorous name joe queen in
and he wrote this book that's basically
a jeremiah against the baby boomers of
which he is one and it's this great line
in there about the baby boomers he says
they were not the first generation to
sell out but they were the first
generation to sell out and then insist
they hadn't
and i think that's largely true of like
every successive generation since then i
think the ones that have been subject to
this onslaught of popular culture and
mass media it's very hard to get old and
not you know withstand the pedia peer
pressure and be kind of like a true sort
of like american
you know um you know rugged
individualist
um in that environment it's amazing it's
amazing to me uh listening to a couple
of the songs the offspring put out
americana they had why don't you get a
job
literally a song about getting a job
because you're a lazy bum who won't pay
the bills then they had the song um i
can't remember which album this was i
don't think it might have been a
conspiracy one i'm not sure uh hit that
which is about hook-up culture and how
our country's basically in trouble
because people are just going around
partying and hooking up and not caring
about having kids and a family and i'm
like talk about a conservative punk rock
band but now where they're at it's like
you put the money in their hands rage
against the machine quickly rages on
behalf of that machine in two seconds
well the rage against was saying though
first be clear that always pissed me off
right um you know they their first
record came out on like sony and
columbia and they're all talking about
the marks and uh they're the minor notes
and all of that they were never raging
against the machine this is this is a
true story at the 2016 um presidential
sorry the our republican national
convention in cleveland profits of rage
were doing one of their um
their lo which was tom morrell's like
side project with chuck d they were
doing some appearance at some protest or
whatever and i literally like leaped
over the bushes and like tracked down
tom morello and i asked him finally
after like 20 years i said
does the irony of getting you know large
crowds to shout f you i won't do what
you tell me you know in unison over and
over again did that ever like occur to
you does it ever bother you
and literally he said something like to
me like he had never even thought of it
um and like that's the issue in a
nutshell like these people think they're
rebelling when they're not they're
literally doing the opposite they're
literally encouraging people to march in
lockstep and somehow telling themselves
that they're anti-establishment at the
same time that cognitive dissonance is
killing us yeah that's a very good point
and i think we were at that protest uh
2016 at the cleveland was it dnc or rnc
uh rnc at least i remember talking to
chuck d there
specifically about relating issues but
you made a very good point you know
there's nothing
better that could be ever promoted is
for individualism people to think for
themselves and to just be critical
thinkers and a lot of these people are
like cheer for me clap for me and you
just gotta love multi-million dollar
communists you definitely don't have to
be smart to be a musician they that was
one thing in high school was like if
you're not smart be a musician pretty
much i was at vidcon a few years ago
yeah the big youtube convention
and i saw some little kids
and as i'm walking past one kid goes
there's got to be like 10 years old he
goes you have 80 followers how did you
get so many followers and then some
other kids like dude i have 93 on
instagram
and i'm like these kids are going to be
narcissists
entrepreneurs
narcissists i want to hear what you
think you guys think about the internet
and how it changed the music industry
completely like we had nirvana you know
didn't just scream it out and like all
fake then the internet came out and
it is kind of awful i mean the
underground music scene isn't fake
that's it when you get together with
your friends of course of course smash
when i was reading about the offspring i
was genuinely surprised by their history
from they made an album that i mean the
song uh tehran is a is a great song i
love that song are you familiar with
with that at all yeah the original it's
just a good song whether whether you
like the message
then they had uh ignition come out and
they weren't selling they were nobodies
the music wasn't popular imagine you
know just like writing music you know
people is not it's not mainstream and
then all of a sudden it becomes
mainstream
that right there is where i'm like wow
that's the coolest thing ever and then
to see how they instantly became just
corporate machine i'm just like wow that
like just that's the whole idea yeah you
know all of a sudden they're like hey we
made it we got to preserve this power
we've made and not be true to ourselves
yeah well what happened in the early 90s
there was a real anomaly culturally um
and i think that's what made it so
impactful though um in the sense that
there was this very much a diy
corporate suspicion culture in you know
gen x um you know punk rock was all
about rebelling against that in in an
actually sincere way you know and there
were people like ian mckay and other
things like that that were actually
committed to that um you know and i
remember when sonic youth signed a
geffen there was like a lot of
hand-wringing among people like you know
is this a thing that they are allowed to
do because they're such beacons of
integrity and of course sonic youth were
like yeah we need health insurance you
know we're like old and have a family
now and like you could be like somewhat
sympathetic to that but it was also true
that
um
the music industry was a victim of
itself in terms of they had you know and
i think they're sort of parallel so like
what's going on today in a lot of ways
where they had like force fed
so much of the same crap to people like
when i was growing up in the late 80s
and you turn on the radio you had two
choices led zeppelin or whitney houston
yeah and that was like it um and for
people were desperate for some other
thing and then when like nirvana and
some of these other things started to
like really break through the music
industry didn't know what to do
themselves they were just throwing money
at bands hoping that something would
stick and as a result what happened was
is you got all of these you know bands
that you know never in a million years
like who on earth would sign dinosaur
junior to a major
major label record deal um
but you know the fact that a band like
dinosaur junior actually got you know
250 000 to record now meant that they
were able to do something great they
never would have been able to do so it
was actually that marriage of sort of
corporate you know um money combined
with what that allowed them to do in
terms of well at least back in the day
before you had plug-ins and laptops and
recording technology sorry i'm going off
into tangent here um you know you'd
actually matter whether you got into an
expensive studio with trained recording
engineers and things like that um so it
was actually a confluence of of
establishment and the underground that
actually made things good
weirdly enough and that was i think for
a long time kind of a strength where
there were there were aspects of
american culture where you know sort of
the trained well-resourced establishment
would meet up with originality and that
was american innovation and we used to
do you know obviously there were always
corporate sellouts but we used to see
those kinds of leaps regularly where all
of a sudden the establishment would
catch wind was something that was going
on that was new and original exciting
and those things would marry up and
we're not seeing that anymore in fact
you know what we're seeing right now
with the media establishment you know
they should be like figuring out what
the next thing is but they're still
clinging to the cable news business
model you know the issue i suppose is
when the left started to uh
there's a lot of things that happened in
the culture war that resulted in the
left becoming morally authoritarian
but because we've always kind of been a
culture of hey racism is bad sexism is
bad we should respect each other respect
civil liberties
when the moral authoritarians adopted
those stances advertisers just went look
nobody wants to be a racist so we'll
just put money behind whatever they say
and will not put money by anything they
complain about it's like the dave
chappelle thing yeah why should anyone
cancel dave chappelle from from a
festival because they're scared of the
activists showing up and making them
look bad and then losing money
so what should have happened if you if
you look at at least when i was growing
up the moral authoritarian right the
religious and many of the democrats were
not cool
so nobody cared right it was fun to be
anti-establishment to rage against the
machine and that's what was making money
so they said
now the the big companies are like we're
going to get a bunch of protesters and
we're going to lose money because
they're unwilling to compromise
there you go then you lose it yeah so i
think the interesting thing is we're
going to start seeing
we are saying this babylon be
yeah absurdly funny and predicting the
future
apparently south psychic prophecy
they do a really good job of poking so
much fun that these things actually they
just end up happening
and it's and it's they've been doing a
lot better than the onion has because
when you're scared to be offensive you
don't you're not funny
so what i think we'll start seeing is
now people who don't care about being
offensive which tend to be the cultural
right with whatever right wing actually
means at this point
they're gonna make shows they're to make
movies they're going to do comedy
specials everyone's going to love it i
think the left is
shutting down their own industry by
being scared to take risks and actually
challenge i think the battle on beam
thing makes me very nervous when when
you they'll do stories and for instance
like just ridiculous ridiculous like joe
biden makes declares it illegal to be a
man and then it'll be like ahaha so and
then no two months later
joe biden declares it illegal to be and
it's like they see that and they're like
oh okay people didn't say no to it
that's a green light let's go so it's
like an authoritarian gateway if you're
not careful satire can be uh i don't
know
i i i disagree i think it's it's just
making fun of the absolute
ridiculousness of our current society
one of the things that i just retweeted
from the babylon bee is their latest
headline saying quote fauci hopes his
experiments on puppies will distract
everyone from experiments he performed
on humanity for the past 18 months so
it's like it's social commentary to the
highest level of using
comedy as a way to make people laugh at
the absurdity of reality and you know
there are some people bowing down there
are some people giving up but but there
still is a need a hunger for those real
honest real discussions uh and very
interestingly netflix um just launched a
new show called inside job and it was
number one trending and i just watched
one episode of it and like my jaw
dropped to the floor i was like no
freaking way i mean they brought up
issues that we would say here
automatically cut uh and and they they
brought up all the conspiracies that
ever existed in a brilliant funny way
from bilderberg and even deeper level
stuff that you wouldn't even imagine so
there they just released a very spicy
cartoon show that that goes into how
corporations are controlling the world
um i still haven't made up my mind on it
it's funny but but it also is very deep
i still haven't watched all the episodes
i'm in the process of watching it but
for them to release that on the backdrop
of chappelle might be sending a message
i might be reading it into too much of
it there's a lot of things i'm critical
of netflix about but um i think there's
a reason this show and other shows are
doing so well and have such a you know
loving caring audience that are even
here when they're not even prompted to
be here unlike cnn cnn has everything
going for them we don't thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time